it often takes a whole bunch of creative
minds to make a movie happen and they
don't always have a unified vision the
director and screenwriter might disagree
over how the story should go or studio
execs might make changes after test
audiences decided seeing the Titanic
sink is just too sad where these movies
improved by the changes they went
through on their way to the big screen
fortunately their original endings have
survived so we can judge for ourselves
Terminator 2 Judgment Day it's now a
massive franchise spanning half a dozen
films and a TV series but director James
Cameron wrapped up the story he wanted
to tell what Terminator 2 or at least he
tried to the film initially ended with
an epilogue set 30 years in the future
Sarah Connor tells the audience that the
judgement day of August 29th 1997 came
and went without any sign of a robot
human war John Connor is a senator and a
dad a luxury and help was given to me by
the Terminator it offered a satisfying
conclusion after the frightening
emotional rollercoaster of the first two
films but studio bosses didn't like the
epilogue because it meant no more time
travel no more robots and no more
sequels I'll be back Titanic I'll never
let go
another James Cameron movie Titanic
concludes out a sweet romantic note old
Rose throws the heart of the ocean
overboard while on a boat full of
explorers actively looking for that
berry jam then she goes to sleep and
dies reunited with Jack played by
Leonardo DiCaprio the great love of her
life it's probably a better ending than
the first one writer director James
Cameron rode all roses caught by the
crew throwing the gem of the ocean into
the sea the Explorers go nuts and then
Bill Paxton laughs like a fool the
butterfly effect the good news Ashton
Kutcher can time travel the bad news is
constant manipulation of time as well as
his general existence messes up the
lives of everyone around him so at the
end of the butterfly effect despair his
one true love the pain he caused her he
goes back in time and make sure they
never meet but the film initially called
the character to go much much much
farther back in time to prevent the
damage he caused like all the way back
he goes back to his own gestating body
and strangles himself with the umbilical
cord gross the Blair Witch Project
this found-footage horror flick ends
with Heather finding her film school
buddy stuck in the corner of a derelict
basement facing the wall just before she
gets knocked out by some unseen menace
this lives up to the Blair Witch murder
motif they learn from the locals earlier
the original ending is more to the point
with Heather finding Mike's hanging body
instead clerks Kevin Smith's directorial
debut depicted a day in the life with a
few side adventures of a convenience
store clerk his original ending finished
the film on a dark note that's also a
sadly unavoidable occupational hazard
for anyone standing behind a retail
counter oh sorry we're closed
Dante is shot and killed in a robbery
just think if he'd kept that and then we
never would have gotten to see the
cinematic masterpiece that was clerks -
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which movie you
think would have been better with its
other ending